[Applause]
welcome to culinary genius that we have
cooked up a real treat for you today
with unmissable tips from the great
Gordon Ramsay today's contestants will
have to just kick scream but mainly cook
their way through two ruthless rounds to
help them they've each brought their
favorite kitchen I am from home now
overseeing the competition today is a
legendary chef from the South Edward Lee
[Music]
what do we expect to see from today's
culinary battles we're gonna be testing
one of the most important senses in the
kitchen taste the three cooks who
perform the best will move on to the
final cook-off thank you very much
Edward okay let's reveal what's in store
for round one contestants please lift
your cloches it's a blindfold and
colored board or can you just explain
what this is all about cooks while
blindfolded you must taste 12 cups of
food identify their colors and place the
cup onto the matching color on the board
the three cooks who correctly identify
the color of the most foods will go on
to round two please put on your
blindfold okay let's bring out the food
contestants you have five minutes let
the battle begin
Edward what a challenge here this game
taking away their sight it's almost
cruel but really enhances the other
senses why did you come up with this
game we want to test a cooks sense of
taste smell we don't realize how much we
eat with our eyes once you take that
sensation away we have to really rely on
our other senses taste which is really
the cook's greatest weapon so I want
them to understand and we need to
fine-tune your taste buds so what foods
do they have to identify they have
strawberries tomatoes pomegranates baby
sweet corn lemon boiled egg yolks
pineapple carrots dried apricots green
bell peppers avocado and I will let's
see if they're fine-tuning their taste
buds
Catherine I'm over here hi no I'm over
here I'm over here what's it like
tasting blind and if interesting I think
you get more of an appreciation for the
texture and the flavor of this so what
are you relying on those smell texture
taste probably taste and then texture
don't knock anything over I'm trying not
to say good luck you're an interior
designer you are used to relying on your
site for everything you do in your
career how challenging is this to take
away your vision I can see the color I'm
tasting so it's actually very useful but
music sorry to know you've had a half of
it what do you think it is oh I know it
is put it there
okay we are at the halfway mark two and
a half minutes left you feel confident
about this
no do you may want to retest and retest
things while you got that time because
you're finished pretty quickly there's
one I'm not sure of I split my
daughter's school lunch mm-hmm I can't
say I know what the color alright you
got a lot on your board are you feeling
like you got this feeling pretty good
yeah yeah pretty confident here how are
you feeling okay I think confident about
what I've done
yeah okay make sure because all these
colors have to be in the right place
okay
[Music]
10987
[Music]
in round one five contestants battled it
out blindfolded but only three will see
it through to the final it is time to
find out how well they have done your
blindfold so you got a little bit
frazzled there at the end I think you've
ran out of time you know you started out
pretty good and then right at the last
minute you just this is what you were
eating when I was talking to you and
you've been hearing it out that was
right you didn't do bad I mean you know
a couple pointing out your lemons and
limes mixed up some graphics got six out
of 12 so 50% not bad oh look at what you
did Cory how was this for you the yolk
and the avocado kind of threw me off I
kind of tasted the same thing but after
smelling it a little bit more it got me
in the right direction you did a great
job I've got 11 out of 12 which is
amazing Catherine it is your turn you
can take off your blindfold this is
concerning you thought a lime was an
orange he said very sweet to you Wow
you might have to get your taste buds
check that a little bit but hey listen
you got an 11 out of 12 congratulations
how'd you get this alright you know a
lot of it was texture mmm I was
surprised how many of them I could just
feel what they were but tasting a few of
them gave me that real reassurance of
what it was well this is awesome man
you did 12 out of 12 so perfect score
you got your lemons and limes mixed up
you weren't the only one to do that so
you got 10 out of 12 not bad
so that means the three contestants who
are moving on to the next round
aww Andrews with the score of 12 out of
12
poori with a score of 11 out of 12 and
Katherine
[Applause]
relations to Cory and Catherine you are
today's finalists sadly of course that
means this is the end of the road for
Vivian who scored 10 out of 12 and Maria
who scored just 6 out of 12 our three
finalists have survived so far but now
they need to make a delicious dish to
impress chef Edward and become today's
culinary genius
now before you select your ingredients
here's star chef Gordon Ramsay to
explain which protein you'll be cooking
with today today these incredible jumbo
shrimp the average American eats 65
jumbo shrimp per year every time I buy
them I try to make sure the heads and
the shells on that way I get to make an
amazing stock afterwards whether you're
grilling poaching frying or even
stuffing them trust me they are
incredible what would I do with these
beauties I would open them up butterfly
them quickly sear them serve them over
salad finished with a wonderful mango
cilantro vinaigrette guys good luck so
Edward what are you looking for from our
three finalists now so you have
beautiful shrimp they're two sizes
give me a dish that is vibrant that is
delicious
make sure the shrimp is the star of that
dish I do not want raw shrimp but I do
not want overcooked rubbery shrimp
either it's time for you guys to grab
all your ingredients for your dish your
pantry pass has been activated but it's
only good for two minutes so make sure
you grab everything that you need your
time and the pantry starts now
I am looking at the pantry and I'm
feeling sheer panic Edward what's in the
pantry today we've got wonderful rice if
someone wants to get a little southern
we got grits in the pantry there's corn
there's peas there's bamboo shoots
there's even wasabi there's a little bit
of chorizo if you want to add a little
meat into it and there's water chestnuts
a cooling griddle
there's way more in the pantry than I
normally have at home you have one
minute remaining think about freshness
think about color ten nine
25 minutes to create a delightful shrimp
dish that will blow Edward away and make
you today's champion
let the final battle begin all right
Cory what ingredients did you grab from
the pantry so got some basil a little
bit of onion I may use that maybe some
peas here some as a pepper going with a
shrimp and bacon fettuccine alfredo so
I'm gonna do a little twist on the
alfredo I'm gonna mash up some avocado
and make a creamy avocado sauce listen
you got a lot of tans going this figure
that coordinated timing is gonna be key
okay Catherine how you doing so far
really nervous nervous okay why don't we
do it's salt I'm actually baking microns
and salt so I'm gonna try to make a
fried rice with the couscous with I
don't have enough time to cook rice in
two sprouts and some vegetables for the
fried rice and I brought my sauce tell
me what it is
garlic Chilean soy why watch my secret
ingredient for if I don't know what I'm
cooking for dinner
listen you have 25 minutes and you're
trying to do something really intricate
so get cooking okay let's take your
Chris Cobb with a chorizo there got a
bit of truce are going on and they
boiling up a couple ears of corn okay
what else did you pick from the pantry
over here so I've got all kinds of
things but I've taken up some some
peppers and tomatoes since I've got some
green onions I'm hoping to do a chili
lime shrimp on top of a fresh corn salsa
with some chorizo hush puppies around it
what are you gonna use focus I got a bit
of a bit of the sorghum for the
sweetness some self raising flour the
polenta pros and cons of doing something
like that yep Pro is I love hush puppies
con is I've had a lot of hush puppies in
my life so it's not perfect I'm gonna
knock me down for it okay I hear you
thanks for the warning Jeff Lee says he
loves hush puppies I love hush puppies
but I'm hoping that the flavor that I'm
making us the flavor he's looking for
did you I did so I brought some cast
iron with me
Rory's doing the shrimp and bacon
fettuccine alfredo
he's gonna carry that up pasta and
shrimp perfect combination everyone
thinks it's an easy dish it's really
tricky you got to drop that pasta right
the last minute time it's when you're
plating put it all together Catherine is
doing a salt baked shrimp with a fried
couscous salt baking is really intricate
it takes a long time she's got 25
minutes and she's also salt baking the
jumbo shrimp this is gonna take anyone I
don't know if she quite understands how
salt baking works you can't just put
shrimp on top of salt and bake it that's
not how you do it
what sort of shrimp dishes do you like
to do all right so shrimp is so
versatile it's great get some vegetables
all cut up it's the same even size last
three minutes
high heat walk fry it a little bit
ginger a little bit of soy sauce a
little bit of fish sauce a little lime
beautiful 15 minutes we have 15 minutes
cuts halfway through the cook-off the
race is on as our three remaining home
cooks pull out all the stops to impress
chef Edward Lee and become today's
culinary genius I want to check out how
they're doing hi there good how are you
doing Catherine thank you is this
something that you're used to doing at
home fried rice is definitely one of
those comfort foods for me even though
it's a leftover dish it's always
something that we look forward to when
my mom used to make it how much did she
and your upbringing influenced your
style of cooking my mom was the one who
taught me how to cook so I would
definitely say that she was a huge
influence my brother was actually the
one that gave me my love of other
cuisines
besides Chinese and you have some
supporters in the audience sitting who's
with you here today um I have my husband
and then I have three friends what is
the best thing she cooks for you oh boy
everything smart and supportive hubby
Thanks well we're at ten minutes folks
ten minutes cook getting towards the end
here so trying to bring it all together
I've got my pasta getting ready I need
to add the bacon now finishing a little
prawn here for the decoration on top
trying to make it look really pretty for
chef Edward so how do you think your
supporters in the eyes where are they
where are they there you go good good
how proud are you of him right now with
how he's doing so far
yeah pretty good we're watching it on we
have him over he mends the barbecue and
he loves avocados some bad he's brought
avocado into his meal today yes lucky
friends all right Andrew all these great
ingredients how much fun do you have
when you're in the kitchen dinner's got
to get up at a certain time so the
family can get on with the night
homework and there's other things to do
so I'm up against that time there to
your wife here in the audience today
right where she Deb is right up here
obviously you enjoy cooking what would
it mean to win oh I'd love it it'd be a
great fun thing and I'd love to take
that home and tell family and friends
that I'm the culinary genius all right
six minutes cook six minutes Kathir and
I smell something good coming from this
kitchen hey what happened to your
something strength - okay let's look at
quickly quickly let me see what you're
doing let me see let me see
give me a revealer give me reveal okay
listen this is a very intricate cooking
method okay you got to keep looking keep
checking them all right what else are
you doing in that dish I'm so I also
have some fun that I am surfing these
shrimp on top of shrimp yep oh there's
the couscous with it that I'm turning
into a fried rice okay that's your pasta
yes what else is going on the plate oh
here's our bacon it's going into the pot
right now okay what about your shrimp
this is done shrimp is gonna be plated
on top allow enough time to plate up
your dishes beautifully so you brought a
cast-iron pan but you're slacking in
your shrimp in
because I squeeze lime on there and do
place that if I took that assitive throw
it on that cast-iron pan I know I don't
press me what's this this is our corn
salsa here okay and we've got some these
are your hushpuppies those are you
tasting everything as you go I am okay
I've just had one and it needed a bit
more salt so I've thrown more of that in
and I okay we're there what's your pan
twice your shrimp and what's your
panties beautiful flavors I got all this
stuff I would say Paula veil on your
plate it is looking an exciting tone
there what is dressing up really I just
saw Cory put a clump of pasta on a plate
that just looked like a wetness
Catherine shrimp or she's got shrimp two
ways she really doesn't have anything
else on the plate I don't know if the
salt baked shrimp is quite done yet I
don't have enough time to put the salt
bakes room on the plate because I wasn't
doing a good enough job keeping track of
time but it just just got away from me
it's not like meat right it's not like
beef you can't pre cook it and then let
it rest
you just gotta cook it got time it
perfectly at the last minute drop it on
the plate nice and hot one minute cooks
and there's a little company's a little
overly confident usually when we have
overly confident and cooks you know what
happens to the inside I'm panicked
I'm thinking can I get it all done and
can I plate it up the way I want to in
my mind oh no Catherine still mixing
sauce come on that food has to be on a
plate clean and beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
culinary genius where it's time for
Edward to judge what our cooks have
created the shrimp have a nice little
bit of brown blackness on I'm hoping for
that to bring a bit of smoky flavor out
but I'm hoping it's not too much I'm
looking down at the plate I have a lot
of competition out there I just have to
wait to see what the judges have to say
it's got beautiful presentation so I
know it's pleasing to the eye and we all
know you eat with your eyes first you've
got some some nice symmetry going on
here you got a little shrimp head for
garnish I like that you blackened the
shrimp you got some nice caramelization
on there let's go in for a taste
I'm gonna hit you on a few points I
think the hush puppies could be a little
bit smaller kind of SOG out in the
middle
I wish the salsa did have a little bit
more to it than just kind of chop
veggies in there but you got nice bright
vivacious acidity in there the scallions
are nice the shrimp is nicely cooked you
did me proud thanks appreciate that chef
where's my self fixed routes fortunately
I didn't have time to put them on the
player
did you check them when they came out
did you actually take one out and you
really actually have to bake the salt
first get the salt really nice and hot
then put the shrimp on it then dump more
hot salt over it what you did was you
get cold salt you just put cold shrimp
on top of it and you pop the gnomon just
know it would have been done in 25
minutes so you wasted a lot of time and
then you had to improvise with this
other shrimp that you gave me
the flavor said did you use your special
sauce on that that's pretty good I think
you could put that sauce on anything and
it would be good but you did overcook
the shrimp a little bit I'm glad that
you cut the shrimp in half and you've
made nice little curls out of it but
because you did that that cooks even
faster I was really skeptical about that
fried couscous it's pretty good a taste
great textures a little off coz couscous
tend to clump a little bit but the
flavor is absolutely delicious
the vegetables are perfectly al dente
they're crunchy really nice job I loved
how you had that whole shrimp right
there in the middle
all right so I got a flag you on that
pasta right and you knew it too
it is so well done it's almost just like
mush in my mouth especially with the
cream sauce that you added to it but
shrimp is cooked nicely it's really
beautifully done
these shrimp this shrimp is a just a
tiny bit overcooked but the shrimp on
the side is really nice its flavored
well but I really love the fresh basil I
love the bacon flavor and I love the
avocado the concept really works really
good job all right cooks have outdone
themselves today but who went the extra
mile to reveal today's winner finalists
please lift your cloches
[Music]
[Applause]
that strip perfectly blackened with that
plush puppy beautifully fried that was
all genius on a plate thank you thank
you well done all right well
congratulations to our culinary genius
Andrew that is it for today